i interviewed you for my channel i think
it was this year
last year right yeah yeah at ax we we
did an interview together and i got to
know like a lot about your backstory and
we'll obviously get more into that in
this episode yeah but uh
as you were saying at the beginning you
before you came into the jab world you
went to
uh like journalism right like with the
baseball stuff yes so i want to know now
now that i know that you were into wwf
before that how did it go from wwf
to baseball journalism it's just
in a company so like i didn't have a
choice like oh my god
decide where i should go right baseball
is like
what japanese people watch the most
japanese people so would you have liked
to have done like what wrestling
journalism
yeah so that was like so that's that was
your aim okay that's pretty interesting
but now you get to talk about wwe yeah
exactly did you get any say in doing
baseball like do you like baseball
uh i had no idea like i mean like i
didn't know anything about the ruth
you know well i don't like it you're a
great reporter great protecting the
space like i i i didn't really
understand
like i never watched facebook i grew up
in
you know i've been to guard school girls
only school from elementary school
for like 12 years i was like in like
gender one gender
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm the same yeah
joey went to an old boy's school i went
to an old boys school
in six years yeah for six years so
middle school and high school
yeah yeah oh yeah because elementary as
well right yeah i didn't know they had
girls only elementary schools is that a
thing in the uk
i don't know because pay a lot i think
yeah it's like private school it's yeah
because you've got to pay a premium i
think if you want your girls to be in
all girls not surrounded by those dirty
boys
disgusting boys stay away from boys
you say that as you're with three boys
okay so i guess yeah so from my
understanding because you were in a girl
school your entire time right
i mean they still play baseball though
in girls schools right or i guess it's
softball
yeah some only a few right yeah so i had
no idea how
the sports
because baseball is pretty popular in
japan isn't it yes it is yeah
i think is it the most popular sport or
is that soccer
i just say it might be baseball right
yeah i've got no idea i think the top
three sports from what i remember here
is baseball soccer and sumo
oh the top three most popular right
obviously they play other sports
like wrestling for example yeah but uh
yeah i think
i think baseball's probably the most
popular right they have like 143
games at least a year jesus yeah more
than right yeah because i i know a lot
of like american teams scout out
japanese baseball players
oh yeah i don't want to talk out my ass
cause i literally know nothing about
baseball
i've been to one baseball game um in
america and
basically the only way i could really
have fun was just to get belligerently
drunk
and that's what everyone else seemed to
be doing